[Musique]
ce que je peux faire pour vous ok il
faut vous imaginer un bipper téléphone
cellulaire et une messagerie
électronique dans un seul appareil il y
a un signal gratuit d'Internet sans fil
disponible à travers l'Amérique du Nord
et personne a trouvé une façon de s'en
servir
oui c'est comme la force
pardon vous avez vu la guerre des
étoiles non
[Musique]
je sais comment vendre votre téléphone
et je sais à qui on peut le vendre mais
je veux 50% de la compagnie et je suis
nommé PDG je sais pas pour qui vous vous
prenez mais d'accord
mais tu es pas sérieux
[Musique]
on est dans une course pour le sortir en
premier et on a une année de retard il
me faut un prototype je vais le faire
parfaitement ou pas du tout Mike
connais-tu l'expression parfait et
l'ennemi de bon
et bien assez bon c'est l'ennemi de
l'humanité
comment ça s'appelle ça s'appelle un
Blackberry
essayez d'écrire avec les pouces
j'en veux un dans les mains de tous les
cadres des grandes compagnies que vous
pouvez trouver on les appelle crapberry
est-ce que donc vient avec nous non si
tu veux réussir faut faire des
sacrifices et plus le sacrifice est
douloureux plus tu vas aller loin
si on met plus de téléphone sur ces
réseaux là ils vont tous craché parce
que c'est les gars
[Musique]
on est au milieu d'une prise de contrôle
hostile
savez-vous quelle est la peine pour une
fraude boursière de plusieurs millions
de dollars ce que tu veux je vais tout
faire vous savez pas du tout comment
gérer une compagnie
qu'est-ce qui se passe
c'est moi qui ai créé tout le marché
t'a dit que c'était les meilleurs
ingénieurs au monde j'ai dit que c'était
les meilleurs au Canada
ouais moi aussi
[Musique]